the honey you've already made it is
measures of central tendency 30th of
January today yep okay that's very very
quickly and you should be able to do all
this really quick for all each of these
what's the quickest way that you could
describe what each is or how you get it
from a set of data what do you do to
calculate me can someone tell me you're
gonna add all the numbers and then and
then Oh fantastic so another way of
saying mean is just well calculate the
average write average in just normal
everyday speaking kind of means the
middle kind of means all of these but
more specifically in mathematics when we
say average we mean add everything up
whoa that was probably louder than you
intended it to be I'm just gonna hold on
to this one uh-huh add them all up
divide by however many that you have
this is what we mean by the mean okay
mode this is even simpler in fact you
don't really need any calculation at all
what do you do what is the mode it's the
most frequent or the most common talk
perfect I'm just going to say most most
frequent was the exact words it's arrays
used and I'm happy with that
okay wonderful and last one medium
what's it what it's mean it's the center
number or the the middle score right in
fact that's why it has me D in there
right so we'll just write down middle
score worth remembering of course it's
easy to work out the middle score if you
have an odd number of scores like five
you just say well it's it's that one so
you've got the same number on one side
and the same number on the other right
so that's easy what do you do when
there's an even number of scores if you
had one two three four five six scores
where's the median yes right yep very
good sir it's the average between those
two right if this was five and this was
six the median in this case wouldn't be
neither five no six it'd be five and a
half so we take the mean like so okay so
that's just to remember what they are
now I'm going to give you about I'm
gonna call it two minutes two minutes
because they're not that many
have a look more closely at that post-it
note you've got you either have one
individually or one between two and I
then want you you've got two minutes to
come up onto the board and think about
which of these three do you think that
description or characteristic fits
underneath have a very brief discussion
and then come up as soon as you're ready
off you go here's what we gonna do we're
gonna I'm just gonna go left to right
and I'm gonna see if you agree or
disagree and importantly why so let's
start over with the mean here a cap
about three underneath here which I
think is enough material find out okay
the mean we're saying firstly that the
mean is the least you can write this
down by the way once we all agree on
where it belongs we reckon the mean is
least affected by small changes to the
data set let me say that again we reckon
the mean is of these three it's least
affected by small changes to the data
set I'm seeing some people shaking their
heads at me hmm
now I will I will point out I will point
out and this is unfair cuz I only gave
you at your table a few to see some of
them contrast with the others so I
wonder I know it's very small sorry I'm
gonna find the one that contrasts to
this one where is it gone I think it's
here we go most affected by small
changes to data set is over here and
this one is least affected so who agrees
that this is the one that should be here
hands up there should be at least one
person because they put it there as
commit okay who disagrees someone want
to tell me why Zack you go ahead
cases small changes already mm-hmm so so
does anyone want to go back and what
Zach you just said so your your are now
asking like what do you mean by small
change is I mean the numbers in the data
set okay so this is really interesting
this feels like ik which that do you
remember the task we did yesterday and
how it felt or I feel like we'll I
should give you right of response is
that what you want - yeah we're like yep
it you're like if the mode changes then
it's probably going to change yeah yeah
I see what you mean so am i correct in
my summary for you is like if there are
some changes here this will sort of
wiggle about a little bit but if there's
changes to the mode it might just like
jump over to a whole thing completely
yeah okay sure all right here's what I'm
gonna do I'm just gonna hit pause on
this I'm just interested by how I'm
gonna put this out of a box
okay interested by I wasn't expecting so
much disagreement first I knew I was
gonna get some let's let's go through
some easier ones okay how about this
still under me okay can't be used for
any categorical data can we remember
what categorical daughters from
yesterday what what makes categorical
data categorical
ordinal or nominal are the two sub parts
right there's no numbers with numerical
meanings so shoe size has numbers on it
right but it's not like if you have a
size 10 shoe and you add a size 11 shoe
you don't get a size 21 foot anyway okay
so so why can't we do do we agree on
this by the way are we happy with this
okay yeah absolutely so this is worth
writing down for all of you okay under
your main column it can't be used for
any categorical data you can't calculate
the mean of you know I'm trying to think
of your favorite favorite musical style
right I was going to go to eye color but
I know mrs. lazy's is the living
contradiction of that so that's fine if
you didn't know by the way mrs. lease
has more than one eye color so can't be
used for any categorical data that's
fine all right next one along it says
this is a still on the mean do we agree
enough to write this down is the mean
easily distorted by outliers is the mean
easily distorted by outliers
yes sir a you went straight away why yep
perfect
exactly so an outlier of course there's
something way down low or way up high
and you only need one of them to
completely throw out the mean do you
agree okay so I'm happy to have both of
them written down in your main column
let's go over to the mode the modes are
ironically it was most frequently used
okay let's have a look
unaffected by outliers unaffected by
outliers hmm now I should say again you
didn't all see all the post-its I did
because I wrote them down but right next
to each other I've got unaffected by
outliers like completely and then
underneath that it's usually unaffected
by Alice so I'm just going to give you a
clue these don't belong in the same
category so which one do you think
belongs under mode do you think it's
usually unaffected or always unaffected
okay so we just we just established
right so now you've worked out this
three that are related to outliers right
so we know this one is easily just one
about allies which one do we think
belongs to mode well you're acting so V
[Applause]
okay okay so the mode by definition is
not related if if it was most frequent
it wouldn't be an outlier anymore would
it does that make sense is that good
logic so we're going to put completely
maybe you want to put that word
completely unaffected by outliers
because if it's the mode it's not an
outlier anymore
so that means whoops I shouldn't have
stuck it unstuck these posters so many
times and that means by the you know
course of deduction usually unaffected
by outliers goes over to median very
good you can write that down now if you
like even though we're not up to it